we did a addition is subtraction
together then we did multiplication now
the reason why I am treating division as
separately is because we actually need a
new idea for division so before we talk
about division look at some point which
is conjugates okay now we've dealt with
this idea of um this word conjugates
before what context did we deal with
conjugates we dealt with it in
discriminant where else do we like the
discriminant is is the part of the
conjugate what where else do we make
these things like early late you know
it's to do with sense right it's to do
it so for instance you don't need to
write this down but I've got a number
like it's 2 minus root 3 and its
conjugate is 2 plus root 3 ok now the
reason why this is useful we use this
forearm rationalizing denominators right
when you've got a denominator and it's
got some really rational numbers in it
you can take advantage of the conjugate
to make the whole thing rational right I
just want you to think about that keep
that in the back your mind what do you
think economy is not in a third context
but in a complex context right well yeah
if we've got Z equals x plus iy right
group I think we write the clown you get
as Z bar at the top in fact we call it
San pomme is it by its just a bit
quicker than saying conjugate okay
complex ones you get Z bar is you change
the plus into a minus X minus I 1 okay
now why is it important to know what the
complex conjugate is why is it useful
what I want to point out here is it if
you got um these are rational numbers so
I'm just gonna call this guy key 1 and
and this girl for she bought okay now
the relationship between Q and Q Bar is
very very helpful right there are two
things I noticed if I add Q and Q Bar
together if I add a number to its
rational conjugate what do I get like in
this context what I get I just get four
right not only if I add them but you
find more to try them which is what
you're more used to doing what do you
get when we do the event this you're
going to get four take away three
because of difference of squares which
is just one so what so what you notice
is when you add or multiply the sum or
product right of a number and it's
conjugate when you've got the irrational
stock the Summum product are both
fashionable do you notice that that
irrational parts just disappeared so
therefore what do you expect to happen
with complex conjugates well if you go Z
plus Z bar right you're gonna get X plus
X which is 2x what happens to the
imaginary parts they just disappear
disappear do you see that
yeah you can't so if you add those two
together but complex number and it's
complex conjugate then what you get is
double whatever the real component wise
but and more useful for us as we think
that division if you multiply them Z
times n bar okay now watch what happens
let's actually write this out let's do
it just like we had out front over here
okay this is gonna be X plus iy times X
minus 1 okay I'm gonna just treat it
like a pair of binomials yeah I've got x
squared there I've got minus minus what
I XY Y X yeah I'm just writing
alphabetical that's my first parry I'm
gonna do my second pairing I thought I
XY minus I squared y squared you see
that you see how I'm pairing things okay
know what's going on
firstly these two guys they're just
going to disappear they're gonna cancel
each other out
just like they cancel each other out up
here right secondly that minus I squared
turns into a plus 1 1 so this in fact is
x squared plus y squared so in just the
same way that in the context of
irrational numbers you can use
conjugates to get rid of irrational
numbers see these are just rational in
the context of complex numbers right I
can use conjugates to get rid of the
imaginary part and all I get left with
is real
yes exactly because the difference of
squares includes the square root of
negative 1 which becomes applause okay
all right yeah kinda kinda they all come
out of this one simplification right
okay so now we're ready to not multiply
by divine so if I say Z equals I'm just
going to go straight to my concrete
example here okay so I think I had two
plus 3i on one - or I said I said yes
right okay what can I do to this thing
well I should be able to write it just
like every other complex number as a
real part and an imaginary part but it's
all mucked up by the fact that the
denominator is complex right now this is
an analogue to when you're adding
fractions right I'll come back to here
if you're adding together this fraction
and this fraction you can't add them
they will never talk to each other right
because there's nothing you can do to
them while they I irrational to get them
to fit does that make sense and this I
also can't work with while the
denominator is not rational irrational
but complex so in this case what I need
to do is I've got to rationalize both
pairs of denominators yeah I can
rationalize them and then make a talk
here I'm not going to rationalize I want
this to be real so I call this realizing
the denominator no joke
that's what it is right you want it to
be rational you rationalize want to be
real you realize now what other x just
like here I've multiplied by the
conjugate I'm gonna multiply by the
conjugate of the denominator okay
multiplied by the conjugate of the
denominator is the denominators what's
causing the problem now thankfully he is
what I prepared oh yeah I already know
what the numerator is
do you notice that like just because I'm
a bit of a cheat right so the numerator
is already calculated for me Soloman
have 14 minus 500 you're right
that's okay how's that gonna chase it
it's just should we just should we just
nut it out okay so let's say I've got 2
plus 8 9 plus 3i plus 12 I squid yeah on
the denominator I'm gonna take advantage
of this thing here right see this part
here this is kind of like difference of
squares but backwards yeah it's kind of
like sum of squares if you like right so
this is not going to be one takeaway 16
it's going to be 1 plus 16 I mean you
can write it if you like but you will
see that these parts in the middle they
just collapse okay all right so now what
can I do here
that's gonna be minus 12 so I'm gonna
write the real part at the front and
then I'm gonna get 11 I all divided by
17 okay now that's fine you could write
that and just go home however it is
slightly better being that here you see
that real and imaginary parts are still
kind of intertwined just just ever so
slightly because they're all in the same
fraction right so better way to write
this to make the real and imaginary
parts more clear there's separation
right I'll write this like so minus 10
I miss 17 plus I 11 over 17 you may
think that's a bit of step backwards
because I got have two fractions that
one right
but really it's trying to reckon with
the fact that what are complex numbers
they're not numbers just like the other
ones I mean as much as I haven't seen a
lot but we're just doing all the same
rules they are another thing that have
these two pieces too